Speaker 1: This is interesting because it's
one of those stories where there is not one
simple understanding of the world that tells
us what we need to know.
Sometimes we need to hold sort of two ideas
that might appear to conflict simultaneously.
And we have a sort of bifurcation, maybe I
would call it, in the United States right
now in terms of the Republican Party, where
on the one hand, Donald Trump is still clearly
the leader of the Republican Party until proven
otherwise, and yet he is rapidly sliding towards
online irrelevance.
Now, you might hear that and say, David.
Sir, how could that be true, how could Trump
be irrelevant online, but be the revered holy
leader of the Republican Party?
And the answer is something that we learned
through the 20 20 Democratic primary, which
is that the real world and the online world
are two different things, which remember when
Bernie Sanders appeared to be dominating Twitter,
Twitter or Reddit during the 20 20 primary,
and yet Joe Biden won the Democratic primary
in 2020 by quite a bit.
We realized what happens online is not necessarily
reflective of what's going on in the greater
real world.
So on the one hand, most Republicans still
like Trump.
Most Republicans want Trump involved in politics.
Most Republicans want Trump to run in 2024.
We see this in every poll.
Most Republicans still believe Trump did win
20 20.
Most Republicans say they would follow Trump
to his own third party if Trump were to leave
the Republican Party.
Most Republicans say if given the opportunity
in twenty twenty four, they would vote for
Donald Trump again.
But then look at what's happening online,
thanks to being banned from Twitter, Facebook,
YouTube and many other platforms for his regular
rule breaking and incitement to violence,
Donald Trump has been relegated to his blog
at Donald Trump Dotcom.
And that blog is having essentially zero impact.
We barely talk about it.
We mentioned today Trump's reaction to the
grand jury being convened against them.
That's big news.
A grand jury looking at whether a former president
committed crimes, but it's barely making news,
what Donald Trump writes on his blog.
Remember that Trump and his staff were regularly
teasing how Trump's new online social media
communication platform is going to revolutionize
everything and put Trump back in the spotlight.
It ended up being just a blog that barely
anybody is reading.
And as The Washington Post now reports, online
discussions of Trump have plunged to a five
year low in the last week.
Trump's website attracted fewer estimated
visitors than the pet adoption website Petfinder
and the recipe website Delish.
So the incredible sort of fork at which we're
arriving is that while Trump is clearly the
Republican Party's biggest star at this point
in time and many Republican lawmakers continue
to pledge endless loyalty to him, it is simply
not translating to online influence at all.
Overall, online influence for Trump is down
about 95 percent since January and down to
its lowest level since 2016.
His blog from the desk of Donald Trump, which
they have been so heavily promoting.
Sometimes the blogs are only shared on Facebook.
Two thousand times we get sometimes 2000 shares
or more of a random video that we publish
to Facebook.
So understand the scale of these numbers.
These are really low numbers for a former
president.
So, of course, the real question is, absent
his ability to make stories viral, is Trump
going to lose control of the narrative as
we get towards twenty twenty two?
How does this affect the Republican Party
in twenty twenty two?
How does it affect the Republican Party and
Trump in twenty twenty four?
Can Trump wield the influence he wants to
wield and be the kingmaker he wants to be
in twenty twenty two without that bully pulpit,
I don't know that he can.
Now in some sense, Trump may realize already
that he needs to do something because we have
reports that he's planning to, I guess, get
his old the dark blue 757, the Boeing 757
airplane.
He's planning to get it back into action for
so-called rallies and for who the rallies
will be and when.
We don't really know.
I do think that if we close in on twenty twenty
two and Trump starts doing his fly in rallies
around the country in support of Republican
candidates that he's deemed to be acceptable
Republicans, that will get him attention because
a former president on the campaign trail gets
attention.
That's just the reality.
But if you doubt at all the reach of Trump's
influence today, look at what happened with
Liz Cheney.
Liz Cheney was removed from House Republican
leadership by Republicans because she publicly
admitted, hey, guys, Trump just lost.
He just lost.
She was with Trump 93 percent of the time
on voting.
It's not like she's some liberal, but she
acknowledged Trump lost and she was kicked
out of Republican leadership.
That simply doesn't happen if Donald Trump
has lost control of his party.
And that is continued proof that Donald Trump
for now has not lost control of his party.
He's losing the bully pulpit.
He's lost the majority of his online influence,
but he has not lost control of the Republican
Party, at least
for now.